[Musique]
à tous aujourd'hui
dans un trou noir
un trou noir est une région sphérique de
l'univers une sorte de bulle
d'espace-temps qui possède une gravité
intense
cette bulle attire les objets vers son
centre un peu comme si elle tirait le
tissu de l'espace exactement comme une
étoile ou une planète
la surface de la bulle est appelée
l'horizon du trou noir elle divise
l'univers en deux régions l'extérieur et
l'intérieur
sous l'horizon le tissu de l'univers et
irait tellement vite que rien pas même
la lumière ne peut s'échapper
on sait aujourd'hui que notre univers
contient une multitude de trous noirs
ils sont très lointain et ne présente
aucun danger pour nous mais par
curiosité on peut se demander ce que
l'on verrait si l'on venait à tomber
dans l'un d'entre eux répondre à cette
question va nous permettre de mieux
comprendre certains phénomènes extrêmes
de l'univers et de rectifier des idées
fausses qui circulent à ce sujet
au coeur de notre galaxie la voie lactée
se trouve un trou noir supermassif qu'on
appelle sagittarius à étoiles à l'aide
d'un vaisseau spatial on s'en approche
jusqu'à une distance raisonnable et l'on
saute dans le vide de l'espace
ici commence notre chute elle durera
environ une heure et nous sera fatale
le vaisseau quant à lui restent
stationnés en orbite autour du trou noir
et nous regardent tomber
[Musique]
avant même d'entamer notre chute on se
heurte à un problème le trou noir
supermassif sa gravité correspond à une
masse plusieurs millions de fois
supérieure à celle du soleil avec une
telle attraction ils capturent des
étoiles et de la matière environnante
formant un ep disque de plasma en orbite
autour de lui
ce disque tourne à des vitesses
vertigineuses proche de celle de la
lumière et perd de l'énergie par
friction entraînement des turbulences
qui les chauffe il produit ainsi un
intense rayonnement lumière
ultraviolette rayons x et rayons gamma
qui nous aveuglent instantanément et
risque de nous brûler vif
la matière pouvant atteindre plusieurs
milliards de degrés risque également de
nous calciné à son contact
pour la suite on va donc supposer qu'on
s'est vêtu d'une combinaison extrêmement
résistante qui à ce stade nous permet de
survivre et de filtrer les radiations
nocives
mais malgré cette combinaison le disque
nous paraît toujours extrêmement
brillant impossible de distinguer quoi
que ce soit on va donc imaginer que
notre casque possède une visière
permettant de diminuer la luminosité du
disque pour qu'on puisse observer les
détails ainsi que les étoiles en
arrière-plan
dans un premier temps on remarque que le
disque est bleu
parmi tout le spectre électromagnétique
qu'il produit notre visière ne laisse
passer que la lumière visible celle que
nos yeux peuvent voir dans ce domaine le
disque émet davantage de bleu car cette
couleur est plus énergétiques
c'est le même effet qui donnent leurs
teintes bleutées aux étoiles très chaude
[Musique]
étrangement un côté du disque semble
plus lumineux que l'autre
pour comprendre la matière tourner très
rapidement autour du trou noir si bien
que d'un côté elle se rapproche très
vite tandis que de l'autre elle
s'éloigne de nous
d'un côté les ondes lumineuses sont
empilées on les reçoit avec plus de
fréquences tandis que de l'autre côté la
lumière est étirée on la reçoit avec
moins d'énergie
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet doppler
il s'agit du même phénomène qui se
produit avec les ondes sonores
lorsqu'une voiture passe devant nous
en regardant le trou noir on note que
l'arrière du disque semble déformés
comme s'ils se repliaient autour de
l'horizon formant un anneau de lumière
ceci est dû à la forte gravité du trou
noir qui dévie les rayons lumineux
agissant comme une lentille
gravitationnelle
en regardant dans une direction on
observe des objets qui sont en réalité
situées ailleurs
[Musique]
enfin les étoiles en arrière-plan nous
semble très légèrement bleuté pour cause
on ne s'en rend pas compte mais le trou
noir des formes le temps si bien que
notre horloge tourne légèrement plus
lentement que celle des étoiles
lointaines
par rapport à notre horloge la lumière
des étoiles nous semble légèrement
accéléré si bien qu'elle nous paraît
décalée vers le bleu
[Musique]
étonnamment pendant les dix premières
minutes de chute on a l'impression que
le trou noir s'éloigne
pourtant on s'en rapproche de plus en
plus vite mais son image semble rétrécir
peu à peu
[Musique]
imaginons qu'on lance une balle à
travers une voiture
la balle est lancé à 90° et traverse la
voiture de part en part
le passager voit la balle traversé la
voiture à 90 degrés
mais maintenant imaginons que la voiture
se déplace cette fois le passager la
voix arrivé depuis l'avant avec un angle
plus resserrée
parce que la voiture se déplacent les
objets qu'ils atteignent lui semble
provenir d'une direction différente
resserré vers l'avant
dans notre cas à proximité du trou noir
la situation est la même et les rayons
lumineux joue le même rôle que la balle
on reçoit la lumière du disque depuis
une certaine direction mais parce qu'on
se déplace vers le trou noir les rayons
nous semble arrivé depuis une direction
différente contracté vers l'avant
c'est le phénomène d' aberration de la
lumière
[Musique]
après ces dix premières minutes ont donc
désormais très rapidement à 4 % de la
vitesse de la lumière et à partir de là
les faits d' aberration n'est plus
suffisant le trou noir commence à
grossir dans notre champ de vision
[Musique]
au fil des minutes on descend peu à peu
vers le trou noir notre vitesse augmente
et on reçoit la lumière devant nous avec
de plus en plus d'intensité tandis que
la lumière derrière nous semble de plus
en plus sombre
il s'agit à nouveau de l'effet doppler
en tombant vers le trou noir on rattrape
la lumière qui arrive devant nous alors
que la lumière derrière nous a de plus
en plus de mal à nous atteindre
[Musique]
si l'on se retourne on remarque
également que l'horloge du vaisseau
derrière nous semble tourner de plus en
plus lentement
l'effet est léger mais tout de même
perceptible
ceci est également due à l'effet doppler
si on imagine que l'horloge du vaisseau
émettent un signal chaque seconde les
rayons mettent de plus en plus de temps
à nous parvenir et on observe l'horloge
tourné au ralenti
[Musique]
les minutes défilent et on survole peu à
peu le disque de matière
[Musique]
quand soudain après 57 minutes de chute
le disque semble s'estomper
on vient d'atteindre la distance au delà
de laquelle la matière n'est plus
capable de rester en orbite autour du
trou noir la gravité est si intense qu'à
cette distance le plasma se mettent à
spirales et très rapidement vers
l'horizon
maintenant les choses vont s'accélérer
de plus en plus
[Musique]
seulement deux minutes plus tard nous
sommes deux fois plus proche de
l'horizon
ici toute la lumière qui provient de
l'extérieur est destiné à tomber dans le
trou noir c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sphère de photons à cette distance
précise la lumière peut même resté en
orbite autour de l'astre
à mesure que l'on s'approche de
l'horizon les passagers qui sont restés
dans le vaisseau voit notre image
s'estomper et ralentir peu à peu jusqu'à
se figer sur l'horizon
la lumière que l'on aimé a de plus en
plus de mal à échapper au trou noir elle
est reçue de plus en plus lentement et
s'estompe peu à peu
le vaisseau ne verra jamais franchir
l'horizon
mais pour nous seulement 24 secondes
après avoir franchi la sphère de photons
il est temps d'atteindre l'horizon du
trou noir à partir de là il nous sera
impossible de revenir en arrière
qu'observe-t-on en franchissant
l'horizon
[Musique]
de façon contre intuitive on n'observe
rien de spécial il est d'ailleurs très
difficile de savoir exactement à quel
moment on a franchi l'horizon
[Musique]
on reçoit toujours la lumière des
étoiles qui tombe avec nous
on voit encore le vaisseau qui resté en
orbite et dans lequel l'horloge même si
elle semble ralenti tourne toujours
et on voit encore parfaitement notre
corps et notamment nos pieds
car même si la lumière est emporté vers
le centre du trou noir par rapport à
nous elle peut tout à fait remonter et
atteindre nos yeux
[Musique]
il s'agit en réalité d'un principe
fondamental à l'échelle globale
l'espace-temps est courbé par le trou
noir et engendre cet horizon à
l'intérieur duquel les objets sont
déconnectés de l'extérieur mais à
l'échelle locale
l'espace temps est presque plat et la
courbure ne s'y fait pas ressentir si
bien que tous s'y comportent normalement
[Musique]
qui plus est contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser l'image du trou noir qui
grossit peu à peu ne semble pas du tout
nous englober même si on est désormais
dans le trou noir son image n'occupe que
15% de notre champ de vision le reste
est encore remplie des toiles
[Musique]
il s'agit là encore du phénomène d'
aberration de la lumière désormais on se
déplace extrêmement vite si bien que la
lumière qui arrive sur nos côtés et même
dans notre dos nous semblent provenir de
l'avant
notre champ de vision est contracté
devant nous et élargie dans notre dos
notamment le vaisseau derrière nous
semble grossir alors qu'on s'en éloigne
[Musique]
on a franchi l'horizon comme si de rien
n'était mais à partir de maintenant si
l'on tente d'envoyer un signal vers
l'extérieur il ne parviendra jamais à
destination
sous l'horizon tout est destiné à tomber
vers le centre sans espoir de ressortir
mais même en sachant que l'on va mourir
pour le moment tout va bien c'est au
bout d'une trentaine de secondes juste
avant d'atteindre le centre du trou noir
quand l'intervalle d'un clignement
d'oeil on ressent une force très
puissante qui nous et tire jusqu'à nous
disloqué
on parle de spaghettis fication
notre tête et plus loin du centre que
nos pieds et la différence de gravité
est tel que très vite notre corps se
fait déchirer
[Musique]
dans nos tout derniers instants on a
l'impression de toucher une surface
plane qui occupe la moitié de notre
champ de vision
comme si l'on tombé sur une planète
complètement noir tandis qu'un cercle de
lumière s'intensifient autour de nous
un dixième de seconde plus tard les
restes de notre corps déchiquetés
atteignent le centre du trou noir
[Musique]
notre voyage s'arrête ici pour le moment
la physique moderne ne s'est pas décrire
ce qui se passe au plus près du centre
d'un trou noir
nos théories actuelles décrivent des
singularités des points où la courbure
de l'espace temps devient infinie mais
les chercheurs suspectent que ces
singularités n'existe pas réellement il
faudrait pouvoir unifier la gravitation
avec la physique quantique pour espérer
comprendre un jour ces hommes extrême de
notre univers
certaines hypothèses promettent même en
cause le fait que l'on puisse survivre
au moment de franchir l'horizon
de plus dans la réalité les trous noirs
peuvent posséder une rotation qui génère
des effets étranges avec de multiples
horizons et d instabilité mathématiques
dont on ne comprend pas encore les
conséquences
mais nos théories actuelles permettent
tout de même de se faire une bonne idée
de ce que l'on verrait
en particulier on peut rectifier
certaines idées fausses qui sont très
répandues par exemple le disque autour
du trou noir n'est pas orange mais bleu
si certaines images le représente orange
c'est qu'il s'agit de fausses couleurs
qui n'ont pour but que de représenter la
luminosité mais pas la vraie couleur que
l'on verrait en lumière visible
une autre idée qui circule et que l'on
verrait le temps s'accélérer et
l'histoire de l'univers se dérouler sous
nos yeux alors que notre champ de vision
se ferait englober peu à peu par le trou
noir il s'agit là encore d'une idée
fausse qui oublie de prendre en compte
l'effet doppler et l'aberration de la
lumière
toutefois il reste beaucoup de mystères
à résoudre et il faudra attendre de
perfectionner nos théories pour savoir
ce qui se passe réellement au coeur d'un
vrai trou noir
[Musique]
non